Hello everyone, my name is Doyna, I'm currently living in Montreal, Canada, but I'm from Italy and I want to let you know that in 2024 I drove my husband to New York, not 500 miles, maybe a little bit less, to the events of the solids and it was very close to his birthday and that event meant a lot to us, not only as fans of the show, but because at the time he was going to chemo, so he was not doing very well, he was quite weak, but I feel that that event made him so happy that the day that he was going to work.
大家好，我叫 Doyna，我目前住在加拿大蒙特利尔，但我来自意大利，我想让你们知道，2024 年，我开车送我丈夫去纽约，不是 500 英里，可能还少一点，去参加固体赛事，当时离他的生日很近，那场赛事对我们意义重大，不仅是作为节目的粉丝，而且因为当时他要去化疗，所以他的情况不太好，他很不舒服。很弱，但我觉得那件事让他在上班那天感到非常高兴。
day after when we were in New York, he had a lot of energy walking around, so that made me very, very happy and hopeful also.
第二天，当我们在纽约时，他到处走动，精力充沛，这让我非常非常高兴，也充满希望。
And I think that he also had a very brief conversation with Josh and he was ecstatic about it.
我认为他还与乔什进行了一次非常简短的交谈，他对此感到欣喜若狂。
So thank you very much.
非常感谢。
We're being fans of the show.
我们是这个节目的粉丝。
It was part of our relationship since we started dating.
自从我们开始约会以来，这就是我们关系的一部分。
So I can't wait to hear more because there's so many good episodes that I can't wait to hear about it.
所以我迫不及待地想听到更多，因为有太多精彩的剧集，我迫不及待地想听到它。
So thank you very much.
非常感谢。
I'm alone, I'll be soon in New York City, when I see you.
我独自一人，当我见到你时，我很快就会到达纽约。
Please permit me to tell you everything, York City.
请允许我告诉你一切，约克市。
Welcome to how we made your mother.
欢迎来到我们如何塑造你的母亲。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I'm here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Hi, Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
Hey, buddy.
嘿，伙计。
Hey, man.
We made a TV show together.
我们一起制作了一个电视节目。
We did.
我们做到了。
And it was called How I Met Your Mother and people continue to love it.
它被称为《老爸老妈的浪漫史》，人们仍然喜欢它。
And they said message, I'm blown away.
他们说消息，我被震撼了。
I can't get over that message.
我无法忘记那条消息。
It's like, my mind is blown just like the idea that the way the show echoes out, it can be there for people at these hard moments.
就像，我的心被震撼了，就像这个节目的回响方式一样，它可以在人们面临困难的时刻出现在身边。
And she was talking about the music of the show.
她正在谈论节目的音乐。
We do this concert, our band, Carter, my band, the solids.
我们举办这场音乐会，我们的乐队，卡特，我的乐队，固体。
We did the theme song.
我们做了主题曲。
We do this fundraiser concert every year at Bowery Ballroom.
我们每年都会在包厘街宴会厅举办筹款音乐会。
Josh comes and plays a set as part of it with us.
乔什来了，和我们一起演奏了一套。
And the idea that that that couple at that moment is just so awesome.
那一刻的那对夫妇真是太棒了。
I just love hearing that.
我就是喜欢听这个。
Thank you for that message.
谢谢你的留言。
You know, I am struck constantly by hearing how many people, like how I met your mother played into their courtship with their teacher spouse.
你知道，当我听到有多少人，比如我如何认识你母亲，参与了他们与教师配偶的求爱时，我经常感到震惊。
Like I hear people all the time, like they ping someone on a dating site because they said their favorite show is how I met your mother.
就像我经常听到人们在约会网站上 ping 某人一样，因为他们说他们最喜欢的节目是《我如何认识你母亲》。
It's just so cool.
真是太酷了。
It's so cool.
太酷了。
As a real world effect.
作为现实世界的效果。
There's something like, it does, it's almost like loving a certain band.
确实如此，这几乎就像爱某个乐队一样。
Like there's a certain frequency that you can assume that lovers of how I met your mother are on a, there's gonna be some ability to connect based on something.
就像有一定的频率，你可以假设我是如何认识你母亲的恋人，基于某些东西，会有一定的联系能力。
There's a Venn diagram overlap right away and then you just can explore, does that go deeper?
维恩图立即重叠，然后您就可以探索，这是否会更深入？
And what it does, it's so cool to be part of people's stories.
它的作用是，成为人们故事的一部分真是太酷了。
This thing we did, you just, the world's hard right now, things feel tough.
我们所做的这件事，你只是，现在世界很艰难，事情感觉很艰难。
I think a lot of us feel it hearing these ripple effect things that happened from the work we've put out there.
我想我们很多人都感受到了我们所做的工作中发生的连锁反应。
It's just, it really gives me hope.
只是，这确实给了我希望。
Everything makes you want to keep putting stuff out there.
一切都让你想要继续把东西放在那里。
There's something in Judaism that is like, if you help facilitate like three matches that end in marriage, you go to heaven.
犹太教有一种说法，如果你帮助促成三场最终结婚的比赛，你就会去天堂。
Or something like it's like a saying.
或者类似的说法。
I don't even know if Jews believe in heaven, but it's this idea that it's a great, you know, mitzvah or good deed to make matches.
我什至不知道犹太人是否相信天堂，但正是这种想法认为，结缘是一件伟大的成人礼或善行。
And I think, Craig, like you and I have at least inadvertently created somewhere in the order of hundreds of matches because of our work.
我认为，克雷格，就像你和我一样，由于我们的工作，至少在无意中创建了数百个匹配项。
Now I bet you will.
现在我打赌你会的。
Maybe more, maybe more.
也许更多，也许更多。
Yeah, it's insane.
是的，这太疯狂了。
So it keeps those messages coming.
所以它让这些消息不断传来。
Those are just that.
这些就是这样。
That reminds me why we did this.
这让我想起了我们为什么这样做。
Why are we doing the podcast?
我们为什么要做播客？
It's such a feeling of connection.
这是一种联系的感觉。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Thank you so much for those types of messages.
非常感谢您发来这些类型的消息。
Yeah, that's terrific.
是的，那太棒了。
Thank you.
谢谢。
So let's jump in to this week's episode.
那么让我们进入本周的节目吧。
We're curdling through season three.
我们正在凝结第三季。
I know, already four in.
我知道，已经有四人了。
This is our fourth episode.
这是我们的第四集。
We're already four in, this is our fourth episode.
我们已经四集了，这是我们的第四集。
This episode is called, correct me if we're on Little Boys.
这一集的名字叫“如果我们在《小男孩》，请纠正我”。
Correct.
正确的。
Written by Courtney Kang.
由考特尼·康撰写。
The great one.
伟大的一个。
How I met your mother's, one of the, I believe from day one, Courtney Kang.
我是如何认识你母亲的，我相信从第一天起，就是考特尼·康。
One of the day one to the end day, right?
从第一天到最后一天，对吗？
Two people in door to door, pilot to Finale, Chris Harris and Courtney Kang.
克里斯·哈里斯 (Chris Harris) 和考特尼·康 (Courtney Kang) 两个人挨家挨户地飞往结局。
the two writers that we hired that were with us the entire time.
我们聘请的两位作家一直和我们在一起。
So it's a great writer, delightful person.
所以这是一位伟大的作家，令人愉快的人。
She was on the show.
她在节目中。
We had her on.
我们让她上了。
We'll have her on again.
我们会让她再次上场。
But we're going to be talking about her really, really fun episode called Little Boys.
但我们要讨论的是她非常非常有趣的一集《小男孩》。
Alec, tell us when did this episode air?
亚历克，告诉我们这一集什么时候播出？
Originally on October 15th, 2007.
最初是2007年10月15日。
Okay, so yeah, so we're getting into season three, right?
好吧，是的，所以我们要进入第三季了，对吧？
Four episodes and that tracks.
四集和曲目。
Yeah, this is a fun one.
是的，这很有趣。
I would tee this up by saying we We last week we're talking to Dave Hemmings and the great episode, the third wheel.
我想通过说我们上周我们正在与戴夫·海明斯和伟大的剧集“第三轮”进行交谈。
And this is in that same pocket of we set this new challenge, Ted is single, right?
这是在我们设定新挑战的同一个口袋里，特德是单身，对吗？
We broke up him and Robin.
我们分手了他和罗宾。
We had to do the fallout for the first two episodes.
我们必须为前两集做余波。
What is their new normal after that breakup?
分手后他们的新常态是什么？
And then third wheel and this one, Ted is out there being single.
然后是第三个轮子，还有这个，特德在外面单身。
Ted is out there.
特德就在那里。
He's kind of almost Barney, he's Ted is the Barney of the show in some ways in these in last week's episode and this week's episode.
他有点像巴尼，他是泰德，在某种程度上，在上周的剧集和本周的剧集中，他就是节目中的巴尼。
Like, he's really out there leaning into being single.
就像，他真的倾向于单身。
We knew we had this little opportunity, this little window of opportunity before he goes on later this season to meet another really serious love interest, Stella Zenman.
我们知道我们有这个小小的机会，这个小小的机会之窗，然后他在本季晚些时候继续遇到另一个真正认真的爱人斯特拉·赞曼。
We'll get there.
我们会到达那里。
This was us saying, this is our moment.
我们说，这是我们的时刻。
This is our moment to let Ted sort of be out there and be a dude.
现在是我们让特德出去做一个男人的时刻。
And this episode really feels that way as did last week.
这一集确实和上周一样有这种感觉。
Was this fun?
这有趣吗？
This is different, this is like a different energy to play for you, right?
这是不同的，这就像一种不同的能量在为你发挥作用，对吗？
Like, this is like a different assignment.
就像，这就像一个不同的任务。
I remember, I mean, you get a lot of mileage out of Marshall trying to say he has the, I love that thing of like, I'm the most, I have the most game because Mary is the goal.
我记得，我的意思是，马歇尔试图说他有很多里程，我喜欢这样的事情，我是最多的，我有最多的比赛，因为玛丽是目标。
I won the game.
我赢了比赛。
Yes.
是的。
But I remember feeling a little bit like when Ted is saying he has more game than Barney, maybe it was fueled by him wearing the belt.
但我记得感觉有点像当特德说他比巴尼有更多的比赛时，也许是因为他佩戴了腰带。
I mean, he had the belt.
我的意思是，他有腰带。
But what happened last week?
但上周发生了什么？
He's got he's got to spill over confidence into the next episode really doesn't form it, doesn't it?
他必须对下一集充满信心，但实际上这并没有形成，不是吗？
It does.
确实如此。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, he's carrying.
是的，他带着。
I mean, he's carrying a huge new energy that he's unlocked.
我的意思是，他释放了巨大的新能量。
I don't think before he got the belt, he would have made that argument.
我不认为在他获得金腰带之前，他会提出这样的论点。
Right.
正确的。
Yeah, because he actually caught he, you know, he got into territory that Barney himself has admitted he he never was able to get into.
是的，因为他实际上抓住了他，你知道，他进入了巴尼本人承认他从未进入过的领域。
That he was too terrified to get into, he talks a big game, but he didn't actually have the game to do it.
他太害怕了，不敢参与，他谈论了一个大游戏，但实际上他没有这个游戏去做。
Yeah.
是的。
We should have, if I could do it over, I would name check the belt at the top of this episode.
如果我能重来一次，我们应该在这一集的顶部检查腰带。
Just have one more little, did you do it Ted?
再多一点，你做到了吗，特德？
I'm not gonna talk about it.
我不会谈论它。
I think we could have, we could have gotten away with one more little call back to that.
我想我们本可以，我们本可以再打一次小电话来解决这个问题。
Now that I'm thinking about it.
现在我正在考虑这个问题。
Do you think that was because the network was wanting standalone episodes and it was soon?
您是否认为这是因为电视网想要独立剧集并且很快就实现了？
Maybe this was our pocket to do more stuff.
也许这是我们做更多事情的口袋。
That was the other thing we were doing in this pocket of time in the series.
这是我们在这个系列中这段时间所做的另一件事。
We were consciously doing standalones.
我们有意识地做独立作品。
we knew the network and even the studio wanted more ones that would just sort of be little like chocolates in a chocolate box.
我们了解网络，甚至工作室都希望有更多类似巧克力盒里的巧克力的东西。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
You can pick them out and that's not really how we like to write.
你可以把它们挑出来，但这并不是我们真正喜欢的写作方式。
I don't think it's the show at it's best and if I'm honest, but you can't have every week be this like really emotional interconnected crazy thing.
老实说，我不认为这是最好的节目，但你不可能每周都像这样真正情感上相互关联的疯狂事情。
You do need some fun little light ones and we did want this to be that.
你确实需要一些有趣的小灯，我们确实希望这样。
But I think we could have called that back but you're right, he's really carrying that energy into this episode, because it begins with this argument who has more game, which leads to Barney and Ted fighting over a woman, competing over who can hook up with this woman first, which unfolds and takes insane twists and turns.
但我想我们本来可以收回这一点，但你是对的，他确实把这种能量带入了这一集，因为它开始于这场争论，谁更有游戏性，这导致巴尼和泰德争夺一个女人，竞争谁能先勾搭这个女人，这展开并经历了疯狂的曲折。
Marshall's little B story or C story runner is just wanting to be important to the guys.
马歇尔的小 B 故事或 C 故事跑者只是想对这些人很重要。
He wants his own sexual credentials to matter to the guys.
他希望自己的性资质对男人来说很重要。
He feels like he's had sex way more times than either of them, because he's consistent.
他觉得自己的性行为次数比他们任何一个都多，因为他始终如一。
It's not a terrible argument, he made.
他说，这并不是一个可怕的论点。
Oh, look, it's the only argument I have.
哦，看，这是我唯一的论据。
Marshall.
马歇尔。
What inspired that?
是什么启发了这个？
Why is Marshall trying to make this case that has been sex with one person, a bunch of things?
为什么马歇尔试图将这个案件与一个人发生性关系，或者一堆事情联系起来？
I'm the Marshall if you should write it in real life.
如果你应该在现实生活中写的话，我就是马歇尔。
I met my wife in college and I always love episodes where Marshall gets to make a slightly pitiful case of like, I'm at her too, because that was my whole 20s, was like everyone being like, all right, grandpa.
我在大学里认识了我的妻子，我总是喜欢马歇尔做出一个有点可怜的例子，比如，我也喜欢她，因为那是我整个20多岁，就像每个人都像，好吧，爷爷。
Yeah, go to the B&B for the weekend.
是啊，周末就去民宿吧。
We'll be out here in Atlantic City.
我们将在大西洋城。
And I loved any episode that touched upon, and third wheel had a little bit of it too, the touched upon that idea of how does the coupled off guy still try to relate to and matter to his friends.
我喜欢其中涉及到的任何一集，《第三轮》也有一点，涉及到这个已经结婚的家伙仍然如何尝试与他的朋友建立联系并对其朋友重要的想法。
And I like professionals with of pathos trying to do that because I have felt that way at times being in this serious relationship at a really young age.
我喜欢那些充满悲情的专业人士试图做到这一点，因为我在很小的时候就处于这种认真的关系中，有时也会有这种感觉。
I always like to explore that because that is real for me.
我总是喜欢探索这一点，因为这对我来说是真实的。
Well, it's good fortune that Lily is part of the gang because he could have just as easily partnered with someone.
嗯，很幸运，莉莉是这个团伙的一员，因为他可以很容易地与某人合作。
I mean, you hear all the time like people partner with someone and then the person.
我的意思是，你总是听到人们与某人合作，然后是这个人。
Yeah.
是的。
They disappear.
他们消失了。
They're gone.
他们走了。
So I think in some ways you could say that Robin and Ted, it, not like it was a marriage of convenience.
所以我认为在某些方面你可以说罗宾和泰德，这不像是一场权宜婚姻。
I think Ted was absolutely in love with her, but just the idea like, well, we'll keep the gang together.
我认为特德绝对爱上了她，但只是想，好吧，我们会让这帮人团结在一起。
Like, this will be great.
就像，这会很棒。
And when they break up, the gang is threatened.
当他们解散时，该团伙就会受到威胁。
So it's really, I mean, so much of this show is about how to keep the gang together.
所以，我的意思是，这部剧的大部分内容都是关于如何让这帮人团结在一起。
Yeah, it's a family show.
是的，这是一部家庭剧。
It's a family show.
这是一部家庭剧。
It's a huge series of long renders.
这是一个巨大的长渲染系列。
How are we gonna keep this family together?
我们怎样才能让这个家庭团结在一起？
And in the end, we do talk about that.
最后，我们确实讨论了这一点。
We talk about that.
我们谈论这个。
And just explain Robin's storyline in this because it's really, really funny.
解释一下罗宾的故事情节吧，因为它真的非常非常有趣。
Yeah, Rob, Kobe is so funny in this episode, isn't she?
是的，罗布，科比在这一集中很有趣，不是吗？
So funny.
太有趣了。
So Robin does not like kids.
所以罗宾不喜欢孩子。
Robin talks about kids like they are aliens, and she is suddenly, she finds herself dating a guy that she met through Lily, right?
罗宾谈论孩子就像他们是外星人一样，她突然发现自己正在和一个通过莉莉认识的男人约会，对吗？
A parent of a kid, Lily, she's just kindergarten, it's a parent of a kid, Lily teaches, and she's dating this guy, but she has to navigate that he has a kid, and she doesn't know what dating a guy with a kid is like, and her reaction to the kid is if she has been exposed to an alien or a demon of some kind, basically.
莉莉是一个孩子的父母，她只是幼儿园，莉莉教的是一个孩子的父母，她正在和这个家伙约会，但她必须意识到他有一个孩子，她不知道和一个有孩子的男人约会是什么样的，她对孩子的反应基本上是如果她接触了外星人或某种恶魔。
She's like, does not even know how to talk about it, but through the course of the episode, kind of forms a weird little connection to this kid.
她就像，甚至不知道如何谈论它，但通过这一集的过程，有点与这个孩子形成了一种奇怪的小联系。
And it goes out like an arc.
它像弧线一样消失。
He was the one who threatened Marshall in an earlier episode, right?
他是在前一集中威胁马歇尔的人，对吗？
My wife pointed out, does it mean he got held back a year in kindergarten?
我妻子指出，这是否意味着他在幼儿园被耽搁了一年？
Is he doing kindergarten for the second year?
他第二年上幼儿园了吗？
Cause he was in Monday night football that episode, sabotaging Marshall from Lillie's class where Marshall goes to Lillie's class to hiding in the kindergarten class.
因为他在周一晚间足球比赛中，从莉莉的班级破坏马歇尔，马歇尔去莉莉的班级躲在幼儿园班级。
Cause that's the last place he's gonna hear sports scores and the kids like, I know who won the Super Bowl.
因为这是他最后一个听到体育比分的地方，孩子们会喜欢，我知道谁赢得了超级碗。
And he's gonna spoil it.
他会破坏它的。
and he's extorting money out of Marshall to not spoil the winner.
他向马歇尔勒索金钱，以免破坏胜利者的形象。
That's what that whole episode was about.
这就是整集的内容。
They're all trying not to find out.
他们都试图不去发现。
That was that kid a year ago.
那是一年前的那个孩子。
So he's still in Lily's class.
所以他还在莉莉的班上。
I know that this is strange to talk to any actors or aspirationally professional actors out there.
我知道与任何演员或有抱负的专业演员交谈都很奇怪。
But if you do a good job in an episode, they might bring you back.
但如果你在一集中表现出色，他们可能会把你带回来。
And they will bend reality to do it and just say he's just still in a class.
他们会扭曲现实来做到这一点，只是说他还在上课。
And this kid was so funny in that first episode.
这个孩子在第一集中非常有趣。
Totally.
完全。
I mean, he was, I also was like, is he 28 now?
我的意思是，他当时，我也想，他现在 28 岁了吗？
Like how old is I know I know is a full year later, Rob Greenberg, Alec double chuck me on this.
就像我知道我多大了，我知道是一整年后，罗布·格林伯格，亚历克在这件事上双双嘲笑了我。
I think Rob Greenberg directed this episode and he directed Monday night football to Alec please double check me on this in real time and we'll take it out.
我认为罗布·格林伯格导演了这一集，他还导演了亚历克的周一晚间橄榄球赛，请实时仔细检查我的情况，我们会将其删除。
He was like his PTM or some roster of players.
他就像他的 PTM 或一些球员名单。
He just like he kept you.
他就像他留住了你一样。
He was like his John C.
他就像他的约翰·C.
Riley.
莱利。
He was deeper cut that he was his Jim Downey.
他更深刻地意识到他是他的吉姆·唐尼。
That's a very deep cut for it's crazy.
这是一个非常深的削减，因为它太疯狂了。
A paper haul.
一卷纸。
Yes.
是的。
Totally.
完全。
He's a filmmaker.
他是一名电影制片人。
love that kid, Rob is like, that kid's good, it's good to bring him as wise.
爱那个孩子，罗布说，那个孩子很好，让他变得聪明就好了。
Yes, why, Rob, why is he still in the least class?
是啊，为什么，罗布，为什么他还在上最少的课？
Who cares?
谁在乎？
He's good.
他很好。
You bring him back.
你把他带回来。
He was so funny, though.
不过他真的很有趣。
He's really funny that kid.
他这个孩子真的很有趣。
Yeah, he's really, really funny.
是的，他真的非常非常有趣。
And he has a very important role in this episode.
他在这一集中扮演着非常重要的角色。
Robynn's whole story, the comedy of it is all with the kid.
罗宾的整个故事，喜剧的全部都与孩子有关。
You barely see the dad.
你几乎看不到父亲。
He's almost not in the episode.
他几乎不在这集里。
Robynn basically is dating this kid in this episode.
罗宾在这一集中基本上是在和这个孩子约会。
Alec, was I right?
亚历克，我说得对吗？
I can confirm from IMDB that Rob Greenberg was the director of this episode.
我可以从 IMDB 确认罗布·格林伯格是这一集的导演。
Both of those episodes and was a super fan of this kid.
这两集都是这个孩子的超级粉丝。
Yeah.
是的。
It's not his kid, just a kid Rob liked and he and Rob was right.
这不是他的孩子，只是罗布喜欢的孩子，他和罗布是对的。
Who cares?
谁在乎？
So the kids there, maybe Lily's combined KK and first this year or something.
所以那里的孩子们，也许莉莉今年结合了 KK 和第一名或者其他什么。
In all the ways that people have pointed out logic flaws and holes in this.
人们以各种方式指出了其中的逻辑缺陷和漏洞。
Yeah.
是的。
I don't think anyone has ever said that kid should have been in first grade.
我认为没有人说过这孩子应该上一年级。
I didn't really think about it until now because my wife was like, it's not good again.
直到现在我才真正考虑过这个问题，因为我的妻子说，情况又不好了。
But you know what?
但你知道吗？
She remembered him because he was good.
她记得他，因为他很好。
She remembered him from Monday Night Football because we just lost that.
她记得周一橄榄球之夜的他，因为我们刚刚失去了那个。
No, he was terrific.
不，他很棒。
You know what really made me laugh was Robin's feeling that he lost the custody battle.
你知道真正让我发笑的是罗宾感觉他输掉了监护权之争。
That's why he had to have the kids.
这就是为什么他必须要孩子。
That was so funny.
那太有趣了。
Oh, God.
哦，上帝。
That's winning.
这就是胜利。
Oh, my God.
我的天啊。
Please don't tell anybody that I said it's so funny.
请不要告诉任何人我说这很有趣。
And one of the other lines where she's just so afraid of this kid is brings me to a fun fact about this episode that I'm just going to share.
她非常害怕这个孩子的其他台词让我想到了关于这一集的一个有趣的事实，我将要分享这个事实。
This is my fun fact of the day, right?
这是我今天的有趣事实，对吧？
And then I'm stealing from him, him wiki.
然后我就从他那里偷东西，他的维基。
Thank you, him, him wiki.
谢谢你，他，他维基。
In both last week's episode, third wheel and this week's episode, there was a Ghostbusters quote that's very low key.
在上周的剧集《第三轮》和本周的剧集中，都有一句非常低调的《捉鬼敢死队》台词。
You may have, you may not have thought about other one and the third wheel when Ted really is walking out there to think he's going to have a three way.
当泰德真正走出去并认为他将有一个三路时，您可能没有想到过其他一个和第三个轮子。
He says, he turns to Marshall and he says, see on the other side, Marshall, which is see on the other side, Ray.
他说，他转向马歇尔，他说，看看另一边，马歇尔，也就是看看另一边，雷。
That's Pete, that's Bankman, when they're gonna go cross the streams on the rooftop of the Ghostbusters.
那是皮特，那是班克曼，当他们要在捉鬼敢死队的屋顶上穿过小溪时。
In this week's episode, I would say, there's an even more direct quote, which is Robin, Robin's having breakfast the morning after she's hooked up with his dad, he's showering, and the kid comes out from his bedroom or is dropped, I don't know, the kid enters.
在本周的剧集中，我想说，有一个更直接的引用，那就是罗宾，罗宾在和他爸爸勾搭上的第二天早上正在吃早餐，他正在洗澡，孩子从他的卧室里出来，或者被扔下，我不知道，孩子进来了。
And she looks at the kid, and instead of even addressing the kid, She calls, she makes a phone call.
她看着那个孩子，甚至没有对那个孩子说话，她打电话，她打了电话。
She calls Lily and she goes, it's here, Lily.
她打电话给莉莉，她说，就在这里，莉莉。
It's looking at me, which is what Venkman says on a walkie-talkie about the Slimer Ghost in the hotel.
它正在看着我，这就是文克曼在对讲机上谈到酒店里的史莱姆幽灵时所说的。
Do you know what's funny though?
你知道有什么好笑的吗？
It's like a hundred percent.
好像是百分之一百。
Those are Ghostbusters jokes and references.
这些是《捉鬼敢死队》的笑话和参考资料。
I don't know that I might have known that at the time.
我不知道我当时可能已经知道这一点。
Sit in there a real easy like.
坐在那里真的很轻松。
They're not, of course, they really work in that.
当然，他们并不是真正从事那方面的工作。
You don't need to know that that's what they are.
你不需要知道它们是什么。
They're funny on their own.
他们自己很有趣。
seamless, they're funny on their own.
无缝，它们本身就很有趣。
Yeah, they're seamless and you're going to get a funny on their own.
是的，它们是无缝的，你会自己得到乐趣。
I would say, I really respect you.
我想说，我真的很尊重你。
Almost more fun for you and Carter than anyone else.
对你和卡特来说，几乎比其他任何人都更有趣。
Yeah, exactly, which are obsessed.
是的，没错，就是痴迷。
We reference Ghostbusters in the pilot, because Robin quotes Ghostbusters, so it makes sense that she's kind of doing her own Ghostbusters self-reference in this moment.
我们在试播集中引用了《捉鬼敢死队》，因为罗宾引用了《捉鬼敢死队》，所以她此时此刻正在做自己的《捉鬼敢死队》自我参考，这是有道理的。
But she's afraid of this child.
但她害怕这个孩子。
You know, it's also like people quote, how I met your mother in their life.
你知道，这也就像人们引用的那样，我是如何在他们的生活中遇见你母亲的。
Like we quote movies, we riff on our favorite things.
就像我们引用电影一样，我们会重复我们最喜欢的东西。
Yeah, so why wouldn't these characters, these characters who are like us.
是的，那么为什么这些角色，这些像我们一样的角色不呢？
Yeah, it makes sense.
是的，这是有道理的。
And in weird moments, you would find yourself quoting a line.
在奇怪的时刻，你会发现自己引用了一句话。
You don't even have to explain what the line is to the person you're talking to.
您甚至不必向与您交谈的人解释线路是什么。
Alec and I would do that all the time.
亚历克和我一直都会这样做。
And I'm like, yeah.
我想，是的。
What I liked, this butt thing that we start, that kind of is at the top of the episode.
我喜欢的是，我们开始的这个屁股事情，就是在这一集的顶部。
Explain that.
解释一下。
I thought it was great.
我觉得这太棒了。
Yeah, it's the idea of when you're pitching somebody, somebody to date, and you're saying to that, but you're saying, you're saying why they'd be so great to date, you're always hiding, you're holding back the butt, but, and there's this pretty big problem that I should probably mention to you, but the idea that you hold that back and we're hearing people's thoughts, we're hearing that part only in mental monologue, that feels like a very real observation, and I love the way it got turned back around at Robin at the end of that cold open.
是的，这就是当你向某个人推销约会对象时，你会这么说，但你会说，你会说为什么他们迄今为止会如此出色，你总是躲起来，你会忍住不说，但是，有一个很大的问题我可能应该向你提及，但是你隐瞒这一点，我们正在听到人们的想法，我们只在精神独白中听到这部分，这感觉就像是一个非常大的问题。真实的观察，我喜欢在冷开局结束时它在罗宾身上逆转的方式。
What's my butt?
我的屁股是什么？
Nothing.
没有什么。
Didn't like feel the dreams, that was Marshall's dig on her, she'd have butts butts, she doesn't like feel the dreams.
不喜欢感受梦想，那是马歇尔对她的挖苦，她有屁股，她不喜欢感受梦想。
My wife referenced a game that her and her brothers have played for years.
我的妻子提到了她和她的兄弟玩了多年的游戏。
Like it was kind of like a road trip game.
就像这有点像公路旅行游戏。
And it's called Perfect in Every Way, but like it's the same.
它被称为“各方面都很完美”，但就像是一样的。
It's the same thing, Perfect in Every Way, but she has a tail or perfect in every way, but he bursts into show tunes when he's happy or something, you know, just like that, it's like one thing.
这是同一件事，各方面都很完美，但她有一条尾巴，或者各方面都很完美，但当他高兴的时候，他就会爆发出表演曲调，你知道，就像那样，就像一件事。
Like, can you stomach this one thing?
就像，你能忍受这一件事吗？
this one thing.
这一件事。
Yeah.
是的。
And the kid, in this case, the kid is this guy's butt, and Robin hits kids.
而那个孩子，在这种情况下，孩子就是这个家伙的屁股，罗宾打孩子。
But watching, like, Kobe was really funny with that kid.
但看着科比和那个孩子在一起真的很有趣。
That kid was great, but Kobe was great with a kid.
那个孩子很棒，但科比带着孩子也很棒。
They had good, like, comedy duo chemistry.
他们有着很好的喜剧二人组化学反应。
They have comedy duo chemistry, and they have a full emotional arc, where she's afraid of him, then they grow close, and then she's suffocated and smothered, and she wants to break up with the kid, and then she realizes the kid actually likes this other woman that The dad is dating more.
他们有喜剧二人组的化学反应，他们有完整的情感弧线，她害怕他，然后他们变得亲密，然后她感到窒息和窒息，她想和孩子分手，然后她意识到孩子实际上更喜欢爸爸正在约会的另一个女人。
And then she gets kind of needy.
然后她变得有点需要。
I mean, she plays literally the attachment style.
我的意思是，她确实扮演了依恋风格。
She goes through all of them.
她经历了所有这些。
She goes through every single stage.
她经历了每一个阶段。
Like she's in limerant, like, I mean, she thinks he, when she thinks he's in love with her, she has to get away, but then once he pulls away, she's like, wait, where are you going?
就像她陷入了迷茫，我的意思是，她认为他，当她认为他爱她时，她必须离开，但一旦他离开，她就会说，等等，你要去哪里？
Yeah, and he's like, you're great.
是的，他说，你很棒。
Yeah, you're great, but yeah.
是的，你很棒，但是，是的。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
您可能是在 Bravo's Summer House 认识我的，但在我的播客 More Life 中，我会不分昼夜地邀请您最喜欢的真人秀明星进行您通常听不到的对话。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
深层的东西，脆弱的东西，不舒服的东西。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我与塞拉·米勒 (Sierra Miller)、德林达·梅德利 (Derinda Medley)、汤姆·施瓦茨 (Tom Schwartz)、林赛·哈伯德 (Lindsey Hubbard) 等人进行了交谈。
We get into relationships growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们在成长过程中会陷入人际关系，遇到混乱的事情，以及摄像机不转动时发生的一切。
New episodes of more life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
每周都有新剧集讲述更多生活，无论您在哪里收听播客或在 YouTube 上观看。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
You know, I love the flashback to, you know, when she says, even when I was a kid, I hated kids.
你知道，我喜欢回忆，你知道，当她说，即使我还是个孩子的时候，我也讨厌孩子。
And she says, can't I enjoy my highlights and juice and cheese?
她说，我不能享受我的亮点、果汁和奶酪吗？
My eyelids and juice, yes, that was a really good line.
我的眼睑和果汁，是的，那是一条非常好的线条。
Did you guys, I mean, you kept layering stuff.
我是说，你们一直在把东西分层吗？
I remember, I felt like at one point, and it might have been because Robin was, you said the one holy, like created out of whole cloth character, she wasn't based on anyone in your life.
我记得，我有那么一刻感觉，这可能是因为罗宾，你说的是一位神圣的人，就像是完全由角色创造出来的，她不是基于你生活中的任何人。
That's true.
这是真的。
There's something about that you guys kept discovering new layers and stuff for her.
你们不断为她发现新的层次和东西，这是有道理的。
Yeah, and I remember it felt like every week there was a new wrinkle in Robin.
是的，我记得罗宾身上每周都会出现新的皱纹。
Yeah.
是的。
And you, you know, gun nut, you had established fear of commitment, like all these things.
而你，你知道，枪迷，你已经建立了对承诺的恐惧，就像所有这些事情一样。
But was this the first like over like snaggle with kids?
但这是第一次和孩子们吵架吗？
Yeah, they, there was, I don't want to have kids, but it wasn't a show.
是的，他们，有，我不想生孩子，但这不是一场表演。
This is, I'm afraid of kids like they're radioactive.
这是，我害怕孩子，就像他们有放射性一样。
This is like, Robin is like act one monsters and monsters and afraid of kids.
这就像，罗宾就像第一幕怪物一样，害怕孩子。
Right.
正确的。
She is like fully, it does not even want to touch to go near these kids, and that was fun to play.
她完全不想碰触这些孩子，玩起来很有趣。
She was a fun character because such a clear voice.
她是一个有趣的角色，因为她的声音如此清晰。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
The character who's take on something would be that she doesn't know what winning means in a custody battle.
采取行动的角色可能是她不知道在监护权争夺战中获胜意味着什么。
That is a very specific point of view.
这是一个非常具体的观点。
No, it's a very sharp piece of writing.
不，这是一篇非常尖锐的文章。
It's a very sharp piece of writing because that's character definition, right?
这是一篇非常尖锐的文章，因为这就是人物定义，对吧？
That's like, that is a very, and it's not a likable trait.
这就像，这是一个非常但不讨人喜欢的特征。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
To make a character distinct and comedic, you have to be a little sharp and angular, and she just doesn't fucking like kids.
为了让一个角色变得独特和喜剧，你必须有点尖锐和棱角分明，而她就是不喜欢孩子。
It's just, you know what I mean?
只是，你知道我的意思吗？
She just, and we leaned into it and Kobe's so likable as an actress and as a person that you feel safe doing it.
她只是，我们倾向于这一点，科比作为一名演员和一个人都非常讨人喜欢，你会觉得这样做很安全。
But I really like, it reminds me of cheers, like how cheers like Carla on cheers, like so sharp.
但我真的很喜欢，它让我想起欢呼声，就像欢呼声如何像卡拉对欢呼声一样，那么尖锐。
Like every, all those characters' voices on cheers were so sharply etched and one character couldn't say in other characters' lines.
和每一个角色一样，所有这些角色的欢呼声都如此清晰地铭刻在心，一个角色无法用其他角色的台词来表达。
Nobody else could say Robin's lines in this episode, and that's a good writing.
没有人能说出罗宾在这一集中的台词，这是一个很好的写作。
To me, that's a good system writing.
对我来说，这是一个很好的系统写作。
I also felt like the more crazy, dark, strange stuff you threw at Kobe, the more alive and funny she became as an actor.
我还觉得你向科比扔的东西越疯狂、黑暗、奇怪，她作为一名演员就越活跃和有趣。
There wasn't a single ball you threw, like an assist that she didn't sink the shot.
你投出的任何一个球，比如一次助攻，她都没有投进。
You know?
你知道？
Absolutely.
绝对地。
And the biggest yes-ander to writing.
对写作最大的肯定。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
She never came up to us and went, this makes my character kind of unlikable.
她从来没有走到我们身边然后离开，这让我的性格有点不讨人喜欢。
Or you know, the people, she's a young actress.
或者你知道，人们，她是一位年轻的女演员。
She had not done much comedy before and it's such a credit to her, her trust in just like, I'm going to make this work because I know I can make it work and I know it's funny and I'm not going to be scared that these are unlikable traits, potentially.
她以前没有拍过太多喜剧，这对她来说是一种荣誉，她相信我会让这部作品成功，因为我知道我可以让它成功，我知道它很有趣，我不会害怕这些可能是不讨人喜欢的特质。
And you actually like Robin in this.
你实际上很喜欢罗宾这一点。
And when you see her start to like bond with this kid a little bit, it's very, it's heartwarming.
当你看到她开始有点喜欢和这个孩子建立联系时，这是非常非常温暖的。
Well, she also has a very funny partner, who I'm sure there was a lot of yes-and-ing going on in that house, you know what I mean?
嗯，她还有一个非常有趣的伴侣，我确信那所房子里发生了很多“是”和“是”的事情，你知道我的意思吗？
Yes, yeah, Karen, yeah, I mean, they were absolutely, she was doing improv with like a really skilled comedian as her husband all the time.
是的，是的，凯伦，是的，我的意思是，他们绝对是，她一直在与一位非常熟练的喜剧演员作为她的丈夫进行即兴表演。
Right, right.
对，对。
And you can feel it, you can feel that she's like trying to go with a bit.
你可以感觉到，你可以感觉到她就像在尝试配合一点。
We should ask Kobe this, and maybe we talked about this, like, I don't know if Kobe knew how funny she was when she got this job.
我们应该问科比这个问题，也许我们讨论过这个问题，就像，我不知道科比是否知道当她得到这份工作时她有多有趣。
I think she didn't.
我想她没有。
Like, she had, like, her comedic gifts kept getting, like, more and more refined and more and more, like, they just kept growing and growing and growing.
就像，她，就像，她的喜剧天赋越来越精致，越来越，就像，它们不断增长、增长、增长。
I mean, I thought she was always wonderful, like, from day one.
我的意思是，我认为她从第一天起就一直很棒。
She was wonderful.
她很棒。
Totally.
完全。
Yeah.
是的。
But the way you guys, like, scuffed up her character and gave her all these, like, weird, spiky edges, and you could feel that she was, like, yes, give me more of those.
但你们这些家伙，就像磨损了她的性格，给了她所有这些，就像，奇怪的，尖锐的边缘，你可以感觉到她，就像，是的，给了我更多这些。
She wasn't doing things she had done before, you know what I mean?
她没有做以前做过的事情，你明白我的意思吗？
like, Martin Short comes out and you're like, pretty confident Martin Short's gonna be able to be Martin Short.
就像，马丁·肖特出来了，你会觉得，非常有信心马丁·肖特能够成为马丁·肖特。
She was like, we were watching her discover in real time this like insane toolbox.
她就像，我们正在看着她实时发现这就像疯狂的工具箱。
This like very deep roster, this arsenal of like, things she's like, wait, I can do this.
这就像非常深入的名单，这个军火库，她喜欢的东西，等等，我可以做到这一点。
But I don't think she ever, we're doing a real Kobe dive here.
但我不认为她曾经在这里做过真正的科比潜水。
I don't think she ever approached it.
我认为她从来没有接近过它。
And I think this is why it was doubly funny.
我认为这就是为什么它更加有趣。
She was just a good, like a great actor who was doing great acting, but it was also like you were giving her hilarious things to do.
她只是一个好人，就像一个出色的演员，表演出色，但也就像你在给她做一些搞笑的事情。
Like her, the reason the kid thing is so funny is she played it like, like you said, like it's radioactive or like it's an alien.
就像她一样，孩子的事情如此有趣的原因是她把它玩得像你说的那样，就像它是放射性的或就像它是外星人一样。
Like she played it like totally.
就像她完全演奏一样。
But real, like she's really in the moment.
但很真实，就像她真的活在当下。
It's not, she's not going, how can I make this a funny comedy, bitch?
不是，她不会去，我怎么能让这成为一部有趣的喜剧，婊子？
She's acting that thing and she's not winking and saying, I, Kobe Smolders, clearly love children, but my character doesn't.
她的表演就是那样，她没有眨眼说，我，科比·斯莫尔德斯，显然喜欢孩子，但我的角色不喜欢。
Yes, yes, she had no air between her.
是的，是的，她之间没有空气。
Like she just, there's no hamming it up.
就像她一样，没有任何夸张的地方。
There's no hamming it up with her.
没有什么可以和她搞混的。
It's just like, I'm going to be as into this moment as an actor as I can.
就像，我会尽可能地以演员的身份融入这一刻。
I think that's what's genius about her.
我认为这就是她的天才之处。
But I think she was finding that.
但我认为她正在发现这一点。
And she's a fucking 23 years old in that pilot or something.
在那部试播集里她才他妈的23岁。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
This is only two years after that.
这只是两年后的事了。
Was she 25 in the season or something?
她这个赛季已经25岁了还是什么？
Like it's incredible.
好像不可思议一样。
It's a very cool thing to watch and I'm enjoying it so much in the rewatch.
这是一件非常酷的事情，我在重看时非常喜欢它。
It's always, I know we've talked about this, but it really occurred to me like the flashbacks, Ted can't be telling his kids these flashbacks.
我知道我们一直在谈论这个，但我确实像闪回一样想到了，特德不能告诉他的孩子们这些闪回。
Like, these are nested Russian dolls within the story that you guys are actually telling America.
就像，这些是嵌套在你们正在告诉美国的故事中的俄罗斯娃娃。
Yes, exactly, that's it.
是的，没错，就是这样。
We're getting to see, we get to see more than the kids are ever hearing and these little side trips and stuff, but it's great, it's great.
我们正在看到，我们看到的比孩子们听到的更多，还有这些小旅行之类的东西，但这太棒了，太棒了。
You really learn, it's a great like digging into Robin's psyche episode, You know what I mean?
你真的学到了，这就像挖掘罗宾的心理情节一样很棒，你知道我的意思吗？
Like Ted and Barney are just a cartoon again, this one.
就像泰德和巴尼又只是一部卡通片一样，这个。
A little bit.
一点点。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
I mean, they're literally little dancing Barney's and little dancing Ted's.
我的意思是，他们实际上是小跳舞巴尼和小跳舞泰德。
It's a cartoon.
这是一部动画片。
Well, it was almost like Robin's storyline in the previous episode was more cartoony.
好吧，上一集中罗宾的故事情节几乎更加卡通化。
Like she didn't shave her legs.
就像她没有刮腿毛一样。
You know, she didn't put butter, she had to.
你知道，她没有放黄油，她必须放。
I also, we didn't even talk about that episode.
我也，我们甚至没有谈论那一集。
I thought the waitress was really funny who- She was funny.
我觉得那位女服务员真的很有趣，她很有趣。
Yeah, I'm sabotaging Robin.
是的，我正在破坏罗宾。
Yeah.
是的。
Robin really loses so big.
罗宾确实输得这么大。
Ted wins so big.
特德赢了这么大。
Ted wins the belt and Robin could not lose more profoundly.
泰德赢得了金腰带，而罗宾则输得最惨重。
She ends up knocked out on the, Ted wins the belt and she's knocked unconscious.
她最终被击倒，特德赢得了腰带，而她则被击昏了。
It's like, it's like Fry's fighter outcomes.
这就像弗莱的战斗机结果。
But we can edit that out, Alec, and put it in last week's episode.
但我们可以将其编辑掉，亚历克，并将其放入上周的剧集中。
That would be a nice bite.
那会是一顿美餐。
Yeah.
是的。
I loved, before they hatched the plan, Neil walks into the bar and it's real quick if you don't notice it, He looks around like he's norm, like he looks around to be like greeted and loved and you know.
我喜欢，在他们制定计划之前，尼尔走进酒吧，如果你没有注意到的话，速度真的很快，他环顾四周，就像他是正常人一样，就像他环顾四周，受到欢迎和喜爱，你知道。
That's so funny.
太有趣了。
It's really.
确实如此。
It's really funny.
真的很有趣。
By the way, he, the plan, Barney Hatch that entire plan, I mean, you can describe what that plan is.
顺便说一句，他，这个计划，巴尼·哈奇整个计划，我的意思是，你可以描述那个计划是什么。
Like Barney Hatch is that ruse in about four seconds.
就像巴尼·哈奇（Barney Hatch）一样，这个诡计在大约四秒钟内就完成了。
The idea that he's going to walk over to the park.
他要步行去公园的想法。
It's so it's sociopathically brilliant and disturbing because he has no time to come up with it.
它是如此反社会的辉煌和令人不安，因为他没有时间想出它。
sitting at the booth, they'd have this, they come up with this dare who can hook up with that woman first.
坐在摊位上，他们会想出这个挑战，谁能先勾搭上那个女人。
In the time Barney takes to cross to the bar, he thinks, here's what I'm going to do.
巴尼走到酒吧的时候，他想，这就是我要做的事情。
He has three seconds to think this.
他有三秒钟的时间思考这个问题。
He thinks, I know, I am going to go up to this woman.
他想，我知道，我要去见这个女人。
I'm going to use Ted Mosby's thing that he did in the pilot with Robin of, Hey, real quick, my friend over there is feeling really down.
我将使用泰德·莫斯比（Ted Mosby）在与罗宾（Robin）的试播集中所做的事情，嘿，很快，我那边的朋友感觉非常沮丧。
He needs to, you know, he'll be cheered up if he thinks I got slapped in the face by you.
他需要，你知道，如果他认为我被你打了脸，他会高兴起来。
What do you say?
你怎么说？
Would She's just somebody slamming the face or pretend to cheer up my friend because he sees me striking out.
她会不会只是因为我的朋友看到​​我出局而打我的脸或者假装让他高兴起来。
And she's like, sure, that's really sweet.
她说，当然，这真的很甜蜜。
And she slaps Barney in the face.
她打了巴尼一巴掌。
And Barney realizes that then he can say, this is three seconds of thought.
巴尼意识到，然后他可以说，这是三秒钟的思考。
He can say that woman's slamming the face because we dated a year ago, but I already won with I already won the bad because I've suffered a year ago, which is all a lie.
他可以说那个女人因为我们一年前约会而打脸，但我已经赢了，因为我一年前受过苦，所以我已经赢了，这都是谎言。
We don't know this throughout until the end of the episode.
直到剧集结束我们才知道这一点。
And then he knows he's going to let Ted go, then pursue a relationship with her.
然后他知道他要让泰德走，然后与她建立关系。
Every aspect of what Barney's doing is like a serial killer, it could be studied.
巴尼所做的每一件事都像一个连环杀手，可以研究。
It's a dangerous mind.
这是一个危险的想法。
It's like he has Terminator vision into the moment and then the future.
就好像他对当下和未来有着终结者的愿景。
It's really wild.
真的很狂野。
Insane.
疯狂的。
It's like he can predict the future.
就好像他能预知未来一样。
It's very disturbing.
这非常令人不安。
But, you know, while we were watching it, I almost said to Jordana, like, as if I was predicting it, I was like, yeah, he didn't sleep with her, this he's making this up.
但是，你知道，当我们观看的时候，我几乎对乔丹娜说，好像我在预测它一样，我当时想，是的，他没有和她上床，这是他编造的。
But I thought I was like a smart viewer.
但我认为我就像一个聪明的观众。
Yeah.
是的。
Like I didn't remember that I was in this episode, and that's actually what happened.
就像我不记得我在这一集里一样，而这确实发生了。
I thought I was having an intuition about the narrative, like where this is going to go.
我以为我对故事有一种直觉，比如事情的发展方向。
Have you literally forgot what happened to the episode?
你真的忘记了这一集发生了什么吗？
I had literally forgot what the plot was.
我真的忘记了剧情是什么。
I forgot it.
我忘了。
And then as it went on, I was like, I think he didn't sleep with her, but it wasn't like it came back to me as a memory.
然后随着事情的发展，我想，我想他没有和她一起睡，但这并没有作为记忆回到我的脑海中。
I thought I was like cracking a plot.
我以为我就像破解了一个阴谋。
That's really funny.
这真的很有趣。
That is the only on a 20 years later rewatch podcast.
这是 20 年后重播的唯一播客。
Could we discuss that exact phenomenon that I'm sure there's a German term for it.
我们能否讨论一下这个确切的现象，我确信有一个德语术语。
And I caught myself because I was going to say it.
我控制住了自己，因为我正要说出来。
And then I was like, wait, I think that is it.
然后我想，等等，我想就是这样了。
And I would spoil it.
我会破坏它。
And I would rather have her watch it.
我宁愿让她看。
What a weird flex to be like, I think I know it's going to happen.
多么奇怪的弯曲啊，我想我知道它会发生。
on the TV screen on a show that I was on.
在我参加的一个节目的电视屏幕上。
It's like, buddy, you don't really get huge points for that.
就像，伙计，你并没有真正得到很多分。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Yeah, it's like a Trump's IQ test.
是的，这就像特朗普的智商测试。
It's like, what?
就像，什么？
That's not, it doesn't seem that hard.
不是这样的，看起来并不难。
You can't brag about that.
你不能吹嘘这一点。
That's a no, that's not bragging.
这是不，这不是吹牛。
Well, he's also his earlier thing of like the snakes escaping from the zoo.
嗯，他也是他早期的东西，就像从动物园里逃出来的蛇一样。
Yeah.
是的。
I like when Ted punctures Barney's, like he just asks basic logic questions.
我喜欢泰德刺穿巴尼的，就像他只是问基本的逻辑问题一样。
You got bit in the eye about the snake.
你被蛇咬伤了眼睛。
Both of us.
我们俩。
different.
不同的。
Different eyes.
不同的眼睛。
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
Why are you bumping?
你为什么要撞？
I love why are you bumping on this?
我爱你为什么要碰这个？
That's a very comedy writer, Ramspeak, by the way.
顺便说一句，拉姆斯皮克是一位非常喜剧作家。
Why are you bumping on this?
你为什么要碰这个？
Like that's a logic bump.
就像这是一个逻辑冲突。
That's a comedy to stop.
这是一部该停止的喜剧。
Yeah.
是的。
That's a wink to the other comedy writers.
这对其他喜剧作家来说是一个眨眼。
That job is funny.
那个工作很有趣。
It's insane.
太疯狂了。
It is insane what Barney, the 3D thinking to pull this off and the idea that it's a great ending that it doesn't work out for Barney and that he just ends up not getting with her either because like it's too fiendishly clever.
巴尼的想法太疯狂了，3D 的想法是要实现这一点，而且这个想法是一个伟大的结局，但对巴尼来说并不成功，而且他最终也没有和她在一起，因为这太聪明了。
It's too, it's too maniacal.
实在是太、太狂妄了。
have to give him his come up and it's like you cannot stick the landing of this because he's now it's too scary.
必须让他上来，就好像你无法坚持着陆，因为他现在太可怕了。
It's too scary.
太可怕了。
It's really ice cold like serial killer thinking.
这真的像连环杀手的想法一样冰冷。
I really like when Ted says the game like the well crafted Michael Douglas thriller or what I was really funny.
我真的很喜欢泰德说这款游戏就像精心制作的迈克尔·道格拉斯惊悚片或者我真的很有趣。
Michael Douglas John man.
迈克尔·道格拉斯·约翰·曼。
Marshall thinking he was talking to Ted in the stall.
马歇尔以为他正在隔间里和特德说话。
The way he comes when he sees his entrance is very funny because you don't know why he's so upset looking.
当他看到他进来时的样子很有趣，因为你不知道他为什么看起来如此沮丧。
Oh, Ted, you're out here.
哦，特德，你在这儿。
Someone with you.
有人和你在一起。
And he gets a number.
他得到了一个号码。
So he has got a number satisfying button of that scene.
所以他已经得到了那个场景的令人满意的按钮。
And you got his game.
你得到了他的游戏。
He had to get.
他必须得到。
I love when Jason said, are you a model?
我喜欢杰森说，你是模特吗？
That one's good because it's flatter to the a girl.
那很好，因为它更适合女孩。
Lettering to the girl.
写给女孩的信。
That's his explanation.
这就是他的解释。
It's not wrong, but come on.
这并没有错，但是来吧。
Yeah.
是的。
I know that.
我知道。
But I was, I mean, I really did think that Ted's confidence, like it's just, I don't know.
但我，我的意思是，我确实认为特德有信心，就像我不知道一样。
There's something maybe, you know what it is?
也许有什么东西，你知道那是什么吗？
It's not just the one, the belt.
这不仅仅是一条，还有腰带。
There's another thing.
还有一件事。
He was bigger than Gaia.
他比盖亚还要大。
Yeah.
是的。
Ted has had a few big confidence boosters.
特德有一些强大的信心增强剂。
He's had some real confidence boosters.
他确实得到了一些信心的增强。
Yeah.
是的。
He's had some real wins.
他取得了一些真正的胜利。
came out of the breakup and was a give-in some gifts after crawling through the muck all summer.
从分手中走出来，在整个夏天都在泥沼中爬行后，赠送了一些礼物。
I caught something that I thought was pretty astonishing in this episode.
我在这一集中发现了一些我认为非常令人惊讶的东西。
You know how you guys have made the joke?
你知道你们是怎么开这个玩笑的吗？
Like, why didn't narrator Ted know about COVID?
比如，为什么叙述者特德不知道新冠病毒？
Yes, or any number of things.
是的，或者很多事情。
He meant he did a bunch of stuff he could have mentioned.
他的意思是他做了很多他可以提到的事情。
He could have mentioned all these things and he doesn't mention them.
他本可以提及所有这些事情，但他没有提及。
But I'm pretty sure in this episode you guys predicted the financial crisis of 2000.
但我很确定你们在这一集中预测了 2000 年的金融危机。
When Robin's saying what the news story was, she was answering- No, the subprime lenders.
当罗宾说出新闻报道的内容时，她的回答是——不，是次级贷款机构。
The subprime lenders, when she's reading the paper, she's like the subprime lenders.
次级贷款人，当她读报纸时，她就像次级贷款人。
Yeah, totally.
是的，完全可以。
But it was in 2007, and the crash was in 2007.
但那是2007年的事了，崩盘也是在2007年。
And I don't think subprime lenders was like in the cultural, like, air.
我不认为次级贷款机构就像文化中的空气一样。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
All right, so Future Ted knew more than we did.
好吧，所以未来的泰德比我们知道的更多。
Well, no, I mean, or Robin had her finger on the pulse.
好吧，不，我是说，或者罗宾已经掌握了脉搏。
Yeah, well, she's a journalist, you know, she's she keeps up and she likes.
是的，好吧，她是一名记者，你知道，她是她坚持不懈、她喜欢的人。
Yeah.
是的。
Could you think that you guys had some like spidey sense that the subprime lenders were really not because I didn't even catch that on the rewatch, but clearly there was some weird little premonition thing there.
你们是否认为你们有一些像蜘蛛侠一样的感觉，认为次级贷方真的不是，因为我什至在重看时都没有注意到这一点，但显然那里有一些奇怪的小预感。
You're right.
你说得对。
That is kind of exactly what went on to happen that was the next year.
这正是第二年发生的事情。
That's really weird.
这真的很奇怪。
Wow.
哇。
Okay.
好的。
Because I was like, oh, they had to have been referencing what and then I was like, no, I didn't know this erred before that.
因为我当时想，哦，他们一定是在引用什么，然后我想，不，我之前不知道这是错误的。
Yeah, the gummy I took right when we started recording just started ahead.
是的，我们开始录音时我拿的软糖就开始了。
Because I am fucked up by this right now.
因为我现在已经被这个搞砸了。
I don't even know if I can keep going.
我什至不知道我是否还能继续下去。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you.
这个老人，他一定要我说，爱上了你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
End of commercials, back to show.
广告结束，回到节目。
The my new mommy drawing is so funny.
我的新妈妈的画太有趣了。
And it's so it's a good twist because you really do think it's when she's saying that's not me, you're like, come on, Robin, this is so like the audience really thinks it's her.
这是一个很好的转折，因为你真的认为当她说那不是我时，你会说，来吧，罗宾，这就像观众真的认为那是她一样。
And it's not she's right.
这不是她说的对的。
It was not her.
不是她。
Yeah.
是的。
She turns out to be correct.
事实证明她是对的。
Um, I have a question.
嗯，我有一个问题。
Marshall makes a reference to mom jeans.
马歇尔提到了妈妈牛仔裤。
Yeah.
是的。
Was there a joke that got cut where he is talking about how much he loves these mom jeans and Lily says, I'm not getting them, Marshall, like stop trying to make me buy those jeans.
有没有一个笑话被剪掉了，他在谈论他有多喜欢这些妈妈牛仔裤，莉莉说，我不明白它们，马歇尔，就像别再试图让我买那些牛仔裤一样。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Or is that another episode?
或者这是另一集？
It may be in another episode.
可能是在另一集中。
I think we talk about that in another episode, but I can't tell you why.
我想我们会在另一集中讨论这个问题，但我不能告诉你为什么。
I know what you mean.
我知道你的意思。
I remember specifically that Lily pushes back against Marshall's love of these mom jeans.
我特别记得莉莉反对马歇尔对这些妈妈牛仔裤的喜爱。
He wants her to have mom jeans.
他希望她有妈妈牛仔裤。
He wants her to have her to have the mom jeans.
他希望她拥有妈妈牛仔裤。
Yeah, okay, we'll keep our eye out for that.
是的，好的，我们会密切关注这一点。
We'll get there somewhere.
我们会到达某个地方。
Listeners should alert me.
听众应该提醒我。
Sometimes they know this show better than we do, so they'll tell us where that is.
有时他们比我们更了解这个节目，所以他们会告诉我们它在哪里。
But if it does appear later, you planted the seed of it here.
但如果它后来出现了，你就在这里种下了它的种子。
He's been talking about these mom jeans.
他一直在谈论这些妈妈牛仔裤。
So we planted mom jeans and the 2008 housing crisis of financial collapse.
所以我们种下了妈妈牛仔裤和2008年金融崩溃的住房危机。
So okay, we're planting lots of seeds.
好吧，我们正在播下很多种子。
All the, so Barney ends up telling Ted, or no, he says like, you're not gonna be able to sleep with her without thinking of me the whole time.
所有这些，所以巴尼最终告诉泰德，或者不，他说，你不可能和她一起睡觉而不一直想着我。
That was a funny beat where it's like, all right, if you don't mind this kind of stuff, I'll take a sip of my gin and tonic and Ted can't do it.
这是一个有趣的节拍，就像，好吧，如果你不介意这种事情，我会喝一口我的杜松子酒和滋补品，但泰德做不到。
Yeah.
是的。
I wish I had played that differently.
我希望我的演奏方式有所不同。
Like, I didn't, I don't know.
就像，我没有，我不知道。
There was something when I watched myself with that drink.
当我看着喝着酒的自己时，我感觉到了一些东西。
I think I would have, I would have just played it differently.
我想我会的，我会以不同的方式演奏。
Like I would have, I would have, I would have, Oh, funny.
就像我会的，我会的，我会的，哦，有趣。
I don't know.
我不知道。
I laughed at that moment, but that's funny.
那一刻我笑了，但这很有趣。
I guess, of course I'm watching these episodes too going, oh, I could have, we could have got a better joke there.
我想，当然我也在看这些剧集，哦，我可以，我们可以在那里开一个更好的笑话。
Like, we're all crazy, right?
就像，我们都疯了，对吧？
We're all like analyzing shit that nobody else probably.
我们都喜欢分析其他人可能没有的东西。
I think, I think it was a little like, I would have tried to have more confidence just up until the last second.
我想，我想这有点像，直到最后一秒我都会努力变得更有信心。
To have more of a turn there.
在那里有更多的机会。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
I love, I love that we're very much the same because of course I'm watching all the time going, I think I had one on this.
我爱，我爱我们非常相似，因为我当然一直在观看，我想我对此有一个了解。
I think I said, oh, we should have mentioned the belt.
我想我说，哦，我们应该提到腰带。
We should have mentioned the belt ones at the beginning of this episode.
我们应该在本集开始时提到腰带。
I've already had a regret in this one.
对于这件事我已经后悔了。
I heard this thing that Ron Howard said that the reason he didn't like acting was because you would wait around all day long in your trailer or in your dressing room.
我听说朗·霍华德说他不喜欢演戏的原因是因为你会整天在你的拖车里或者更衣室里等着。
get called in, you do it like three times, because they're running out of, you know, day, they had to end.
被叫进来，你会这样做三遍，因为他们已经没有时间了，你知道，他们必须结束。
Yeah.
是的。
And then in the drive home, you realize how you should have done it.
然后在开车回家的路上，你意识到你应该如何做到这一点。
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
It's brutal.
太残酷了。
And it's forget it.
忘记它了。
It's gone.
它消失了。
It's committed to film forever.
它永远致力于电影。
And the thing you did that you don't think was as good as it could be, it's just going to play forever.
你所做的事情，你认为没有那么好，它只会永远持续下去。
It's going to be the world forever.
这将是永远的世界。
Yeah.
是的。
The thing that I loved when I did this TV show, Hunters with Al Pacino, I loved watching him work because I felt like by the time the scene, what they moved on from a scene, yeah, he had done it five or six or seven totally different ways.
当我和阿尔·帕西诺一起拍这部电视剧《猎人》时，我喜欢看他的工作，因为我觉得当场景发生时，他们从一个场景中继续前进，是的，他已经用五、六或七种完全不同的方式做到了。
Is that what he did?
他就是这么做的吗？
He would make sure to make to give a bunch of different versions.
他一定会提供一堆不同的版本。
He would just vary it up.
他只会改变它。
And he I never got the feeling that he wasn't he obviously was up to the editor to pick the take.
我从来没有感觉到他不是，他显然是由剪辑师来选择的。
Yeah.
是的。
But I always felt like he at least got that feeling out of his body that he could have done in a different way.
但我总觉得他至少从身体里得到了那种他可以用不同的方式做到的感觉。
Right.
正确的。
Because he did it all the ways, he did it all the ways, so he could like move on with his life.
因为他做了所有的事情，他做了所有的事情，所以他可以继续他的生活。
That's great, but that's hard to do unless you're Al Pacino and his age, right?
这很好，但是除非你是阿尔·帕西诺并且是他的年纪，否则很难做到，对吧？
In some ways, yes.
在某些方面，是的。
He's a little bit hard to do that when you're 28 or whatever.
当你28岁或者其他年龄的时候，他有点难以做到这一点。
Yes, that's right.
是的，没错。
That's right.
这是正确的。
Like, I think the thing is, but he had to have, he became Al Pacino because he was also brave, and that's true.
就像，我认为问题是，但他必须这样做，他成为阿尔·帕西诺，因为他也很勇敢，这是事实。
Tried all the things.
尝试了所有的事情。
Like, I don't know if it's chicken rag.
就像，我不知道这是不是鸡肉抹布。
I do think that older actors, especially film actors get, get pretty ballsy with what they'll try or not, you know.
我确实认为老演员，尤其是电影演员，对于他们会尝试或不尝试的事情会变得非常大胆，你知道。
My feeling with him was I always felt like his self-esteem was not dependent on the last take he just did.
我对他的感觉是，我总觉得他的自尊并不取决于他刚刚拍的最后一张照片。
And when you're 28, it kind of is.
当你28岁的时候，确实如此。
Like you think, I remember in grad school feeling like my whole first year and a half that I was still auditioning for the school.
就像你想的那样，我记得在研究生院的第一年半，我一直在为学校试镜。
Every time I got up, I felt like it was a referendum on my talent and my right to be there.
每次我起床，我都觉得这是对我的才华和我在那里的权利的一次公投。
And it's cool when you you work with like great iconic actors, they just, like, Pachino, like, and I don't even think he'd mind me saying this, like, sometimes he like, he couldn't find it, or he blew, like, and it was so awesome to watch, because then it's like a golfer who can shake off the last shot, you know?
当你和伟大的标志性演员一起工作时，这很酷，他们只是，就像，帕基诺，就像，我什至不认为他会介意我这么说，就像，有时他喜欢，他找不到它，或者他吹了，就像，观看起来真是太棒了，因为那样就像一个高尔夫球手可以摆脱最后一杆，你知道吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
He would just like find something incredible the next day, and he would sometimes turn to us and go, that was the one, because I had the thought, I had the thought in my head for that one.
他只是想第二天发现一些令人难以置信的东西，有时他会转向我们然后走，就是这样，因为我有这个想法，我脑子里有那个想法。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
It was all about thinking for him.
一切都是为他着想。
Yeah, that's so cool.
是的，那太酷了。
Super cool.
超级酷。
Yeah, I think that the tiny Barney's, you know, talking Ted, and I think for me, that's another example of like, this was a hybrid.
是的，我认为小巴尼，你知道，正在说话的泰德，我想对我来说，这是另一个例子，这是一个混合体。
We had graphics, we had post-production.
我们有图形，我们有后期制作。
You could not do that.
你不能那样做。
That was a little elaborate thing to do.
这是一件有点复杂的事情。
That was like, we were creating like blue-screen climbing walls for Barney to like, I was trying to remember what that's body.
就像，我们正在为巴尼创造类似的蓝屏攀岩墙，我试图记住那是什么身体。
Yeah, like we, I think we built like a playground of like clammable, like blue screen or green screen covered, like climbing structure.
是的，就像我们一样，我认为我们建造了一个类似可攀爬的游乐场，像蓝色屏幕或绿色屏幕覆盖，像攀爬结构。
I almost can't remember what it looked like, what it was, but he's like scaling climbing mountains and doing moves and he's lying in certain ways that we're gonna be placed on her body.
我几乎不记得它是什么样子，它是什么，但他就像爬山和做动作，他以某种方式躺着，我们将被放在她的身体上。
That was like a very elaborate thing to shoot Neil on like the green screen or whatever.
这对于拍摄尼尔来说就像是一个非常复杂的事情，就像绿屏或其他什么一样。
And then a very elaborate composite with the special factiles, like not every sitcom was doing that.
然后是一个非常复杂的与特殊设施的合成，就像不是每个情景喜剧都这样做一样。
And it was very cool, very memorable, very trippy to look at.
它非常酷，非常令人难忘，看起来非常迷幻。
I liked it a lot.
我非常喜欢它。
I do remember the day that I had to do the dancing at the end.
我确实记得最后我必须跳舞的那一天。
You were probably on a green screen somewhere, and we go, okay, now dance to reggae.
你可能在某个地方的绿屏上，然后我们就开始，好吧，现在随着雷鬼音乐跳舞。
I was wondering what that felt like.
我想知道那是什么感觉。
Is that like a panic attack?
这就像惊恐发作吗？
Like, what am I doing?
就像，我在做什么？
Well, I'll tell you what helped me.
好吧，我会告诉你什么对我有帮助。
I'll tell you what helped me so much.
我会告诉你是什么对我有如此大的帮助。
Courtney Kang, I remember her, she was on set.
考特尼·康，我记得她，她在片场。
She was on set all week, I remember.
我记得她整个星期都在片场。
But she thought my moves were so funny.
但她觉得我的举动很有趣。
And she kept laughing like, and she had a very distinctive laugh.
而且她一直在笑，而且笑得很有特色。
of course, like a very charming, great distinctive laugh.
当然，喜欢非常迷人、很有特色的笑声。
So I was doing this dancing and it was absurd.
所以我在跳这种舞蹈，这很荒谬。
And I can't remember, it wasn't like in, you know, the background like of a club scene where they'll play the music to give you the vibe, but then they have to turn the music off and the background actors have to keep dancing.
我不记得了，这不像俱乐部场景那样，他们会播放音乐来给你带来共鸣，但随后他们必须关掉音乐，背景演员必须继续跳舞。
It wasn't like that because I think- There was a dialogue.
事情并非如此，因为我认为——有一段对话。
I think you're just dancing.
我认为你只是在跳舞。
There wasn't dialogue.
没有对话。
So they just hyped in like a really loud song and they just had me dance for like 90 seconds or two minutes, but I was really going for it.
所以他们就像一首非常响亮的歌曲一样大肆宣传，他们只是让我跳舞大约 90 秒或两分钟，但我真的很想跳。
And I remember- It was funny.
我记得——这很有趣。
I remember Courtney laughing so hard at my moves and it gave me like a lot of confidence.
我记得考特尼对我的动作笑得很厉害，这给了我很大的信心。
See, it matters.
瞧，这很重要。
This is why like, writers should be on set with actors.
这就是为什么编剧应该和演员一起在片场。
This is part of what writer's guild is fighting for.
这是作家协会为之奋斗的一部分。
Part of what the big companies are trying to cut the writers out of the process.
大公司正试图将编剧排除在这一过程之外。
So they wrote the scripts go away.
所以他们写了剧本走开。
You're just saying that literally the writer being there laughing was unlocking your confidence.
你只是说，从字面上看，作者在那里大笑，释放了你的信心。
like that says a lot, actually.
实际上，这说明了很多。
Like that's a good ad for, that's as good as coming in and giving a note or giving an alt pitch.
就像这是一个很好的广告一样，这与进来并给出注释或给出替代方案一样好。
Like she made you loose enough to do that by laughing and she does have a great laugh.
就像她让你足够放松，可以通过笑来做到这一点，而且她确实笑得很开心。
I just was listening to Nikki Glaser, whose new special is really funny.
我刚刚在听 Nikki Glaser，她的新专辑真的很有趣。
My wife and I are about to finish it.
我和我的妻子即将完成它。
But she was on Dax Shepard's podcast and she's talking about like she has to go do the Jennifer Hudson's show and they have this thing called The Spirit Tunnel where they sing a song about you and all the producers like Sarah need you.
但她在戴克斯·谢泼德的播客上，她说她必须去参加詹妮弗·哈德森的节目，他们有一个叫做“精神隧道”的东西，他们在那里唱一首关于你的歌，所有像莎拉这样的制作人都需要你。
And you have to, you have to dance down this hallway.
你必须，你必须在走廊里跳舞。
And she said her biggest nightmare is like, and it goes viral, like people love them.
她说她最大的噩梦就是，它像病毒一样传播开来，就像人们爱他们一样。
It's like the most popular, it's a really like popular segment.
这就像最受欢迎的部分，这是一个非常受欢迎的部分。
And she said she's had nightmares about like, when am I gonna be asked to do that?
她说她做了噩梦，比如，我什么时候会被要求这样做？
Like do the show and she finally had to do it.
就像做节目一样，她最终不得不这样做。
And she's like, no, I can't dance.
她说，不，我不会跳舞。
If she's like, I can dance if I'm not the only, You shouldn't want to be spot lit as a dancer, right?
如果她说，如果我不是唯一的，我就可以跳舞，你不应该想成为一名舞者，对吧？
Like it's, I find that like when I'm dancing, like when I'm at Burning Man, I mean you having a little assist there, if you know what I mean.
就像它一样，我发现就像当我跳舞时，就像当我在火人节时，我的意思是你在那里得到了一点帮助，如果你明白我的意思的话。
But when I'm at Burning Man or like at a wedding or something, and a lot of people are dancing, I can really relax into dancing.
但是当我在火人节或者婚礼之类的时候，很多人都在跳舞，我真的可以放松地跳舞。
But like throw me in the middle of a circle where everyone's staring at me dancing.
但就像把我扔到一个圆圈中间，每个人都盯着我跳舞。
It's like a stress dream.
这就像一个压力梦。
And I was thinking, I really thought of this.
我在想，我真的想到了这一点。
I'm glad we're talking about this because watching it last night, I thought Josh actually seems like he's having fun he's loose doing this.
我很高兴我们谈论这个，因为昨晚看了它，我认为乔什实际上看起来很开心，他可以轻松地做这件事。
I'm telling you, it was because Courtney was laughing at me and enjoying it.
我告诉你，那是因为考特尼在嘲笑我并且很享受。
Because I was thinking to myself, how is he actually seeming that fun and silly and light doing it because I was imagining 50 crew people and lights around you and like hundreds of thousands of dollars being spent on basically saying, hey, Josh, now do a funny dance and everyone's staring at you and there's sound rolling and there's lights and it's just so stupid.
因为我在心里想，他怎么会显得那么有趣、愚蠢、轻松呢？因为我想象着你周围有 50 名工作人员和灯光，就像花了数十万美元基本上说，嘿，乔什，现在跳一支有趣的舞蹈，每个人都盯着你，声音滚滚，灯光闪烁，这太愚蠢了。
And you know you're going to be shrunk down and put into a funny video effect and be dancing on someone's shoulder.
而且你知道你会被缩小并进入有趣的视频效果并在某人的肩膀上跳舞。
But in that moment, you're a real-sized human, dancing and a lot of people.
但在那一刻，你就是一个真实大小的人，跳舞，还有很多人。
Well, it was also just me and the crew and Robin Courtney, right?
好吧，也只有我和工作人员以及罗宾·考特尼，对吧？
There was no one around.
周围没有人。
It wasn't like, I just felt like I was there.
并不是这样，我只是觉得我就在那里。
I felt like I got to be uncorked and silly.
我觉得我必须被打开并变得愚蠢。
And it was great.
这太棒了。
So thank you, Courtney, all these years later, for enjoying my dancing so much.
所以，谢谢你，考特尼，这么多年过去了，谢谢你这么喜欢我的舞蹈。
I love that detail so much.
我非常喜欢这个细节。
And it's writers should be on sets with actors full stop.
而且编剧应该和演员一起在片场。
There's no argument.
没有什么可争论的。
Agreed.
同意。
Great.
伟大的。
Well, cool.
嗯，很酷。
This is a fun one.
这是一件有趣的事。
Good job, Courtney.
干得好，考特尼。
Good job.
好工作。
Tiny dancing.
小舞。
Josh.
乔什。
It was a little more ABC story like versus last week because we were just talking about third wheel that was everyone was on Ted's train and I do think sometimes those episodes have a kind of momentum I really like.
与上周相比，这更像是 ABC 的故事，因为我们只是在谈论第三轮，每个人都在特德的火车上，我确实认为有时这些剧集有一种我非常喜欢的动力。
This was a little more like these guys are on a track, you know, Robin's on a track and like Marshall and Lily are kind of like dipping a toe into those two tracks.
这更像是这些家伙在一条轨道上，你知道，罗宾在一条轨道上，就像马歇尔和莉莉一样，有点像涉足这两条轨道。
Now, it wasn't quite, it not every week can be everyone's like diffusing a bomb together.
现在，情况不完全是这样，不是每个星期每个人都能像一起散布炸弹一样。
But I was a nice double entendre on the title also.
但我对标题的理解也是一个很好的双关语。
Little Boys had all kinds of meetings, you know, Barney and Ted were having a ridiculous and somewhat transactional competition for a woman and they were kind of behaving like little boys having a competition and it literally became little dancing boys on this woman's body.
小男孩们举行了各种各样的会议，你知道，巴尼和特德正在为一个女人进行一场荒谬的、有点交易性的竞争，他们的行为有点像小男孩在竞争，而它实际上变成了这个女人身上跳舞的小男孩。
And neither of them really wound up getting the girl, which again, is that nice puncturing of like, well, when these guys do something a little douchey, it's kind of nice to actually see them not win.
他们俩最终都没有真正得到那个女孩，这又是一种很好的刺痛，好吧，当这些家伙做了一些有点愚蠢的事情时，看到他们没有获胜真是太好了。
I really like the sweet flash forward, which again is one thing that only himium can do.
我真的很喜欢甜蜜的快进，这又是只有 Himium 才能做到的一件事。
Not every sitcom can do this.
不是每个情景喜剧都能做到这一点。
Just Future Ted saying, as you know, you're where Aunt Robin did develop a good relationship with kids and wound up being the featured model and some wonderful pieces of art.
只是未来泰德说，如你所知，罗宾阿姨确实与孩子们建立了良好的关系，并最终成为特色模特和一些精彩的艺术品。
And then you see these drawings of Ted's younger kids and we know them that made over the years of Robin.
然后你会看到泰德年幼的孩子们的这些画，我们知道它们是罗宾多年来创作的。
It tells you she has remained a part of their lives and a part of Ted's life and the power of that little button on the episode to me elevates the whole episode in this way that really makes it matter and really makes it a Robin story, which I really like.
它告诉你，她仍然是他们生活的一部分，也是泰德生活的一部分，对我来说，这一集中那个小按钮的力量以这种方式提升了整个情节，这确实使它变得重要，并真正使它成为罗宾的故事，我真的很喜欢。
Yeah, I love that.
是的，我喜欢那个。
I thought it was very moving.
我觉得这很感人。
And just a shout out to Janet Varney, who played Stacy.
向扮演史黛西的珍妮特·瓦尼致敬。
She was so funny.
她真是太有趣了。
Watching her play that bass was, was she really a bass player?
看着她弹贝斯，她真的是贝斯手吗？
I don't know if she.
我不知道她是不是。
I was trying to figure that out, because she looked, she kind of looked pretty convincing with her sort of left-handed fret work there.
我试图弄清楚这一点，因为她看起来，她的左手音品工作看起来相当令人信服。
And the bass did, I don't remember if she was really doing anything, but if not, it was some really good bass acting.
贝斯也做到了，我不记得她是否真的做了什么，但如果没有，那也是一些非常好的贝斯表演。
And her whole thing about the day that Varney's gonna have to go to, and they're not sleeping together.
还有她关于瓦尼要去的那天的全部事情，而且他们没有睡在一起。
He's just going to have to go to this, like, muddy outdoor reggae festival and it's going to rain all day.
他必须去参加这个泥泞的户外雷鬼音乐节，而且一整天都会下雨。
Yeah.
是的。
She wants to get there somewhere in a 14-hour window she was going to play.
她想在 14 小时内到达她要玩的某个地方。
Yeah.
是的。
That was funny.
这很有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
She was great.
她很棒。
Thank you very much.
非常感谢。
It was just a great cast.
这真是一个伟大的演员阵容。
It was a great episode.
这是一个很棒的插曲。
Go, Courtney Kang, another Courtney Kang hit.
去吧，考特尼·康，另一个考特尼·康的热门歌曲。
And yeah, that was a great one.
是的，那是一件很棒的事情。
Welcome back to what we in the podcast game called the C-block.
欢迎回到我们在播客游戏中称为 C 块的内容。
C-block.
C 块。
The C-block.
C-block.
C 块。
Why do we do that?
我们为什么要这么做？
I don't know.
我不知道。
I like it though.
不过我喜欢它。
I like it too.
我也喜欢它。
It's another Ghostbusters reference.
这是另一个《捉鬼敢死队》的参考。
So we love to read a letter that we've received from how I met your mother, fans and lovers of the show, friends of the pod, and Craig is going to read this week's letter.
因此，我们很高兴阅读一封信，这封信是我与你的母亲、节目的粉丝和爱好者、豆荚的朋友们见面时收到的，克雷格将阅读本周的这封信。
Take it away, Craig.
把它拿走，克雷格。
where we read these as cold as possible.
我们尽可能冷地阅读这些内容。
We haven't usually pre-read them, but I see the name Wesleyan University in it, which is where I went to college with Alec Lev, and I'm at Carter Bayes, and I met my wife, so I thought Wesleyan's in there, so I'll read this one.
我们通常不会预读它们，但我在其中看到卫斯理大学这个名字，这是我和亚历克·列夫一起上大学的地方，我在卡特贝叶斯大学，我遇到了我的妻子，所以我以为卫斯理大学就在那里，所以我会读这一篇。
Okay, dear William Yang, I am Lizette, an almost 30 year old writer from the humble utopia of Connecticut.
好吧，亲爱的威廉·杨，我是莉泽特，一位来自康涅狄格州简陋乌托邦的快三十岁的作家。
How I Met Your Mother has been a dynamic character in the story of my young adulthood, starting in my senior year of high school.
《老爸老妈的浪漫史》从高中四年级开始，一直是我青年时期故事中的一个充满活力的人物。
It was my older sister who attended Wesleyan University during the show's final years, who inspired me to start watching the show.
是我的姐姐在节目的最后几年就读卫斯理大学，她激励我开始观看节目。
Minutes into the pilot, I realized it was no longer about wanting to like the same things as my cool big sister.
试播几分钟后，我意识到这不再是想要和我酷酷的姐姐喜欢同样的事情。
This was something that spoke to my soul in a way no sitcom had before.
这是情景喜剧以前从未有过的方式与我的灵魂对话的东西。
I instantly felt seen by Ted's unapologetic yearning for the certainty of the one, and hoped I'd get lucky like Marshall and Lily once I got to college.
我立刻就被泰德对确定性的无悔渴望所看到，并希望一旦我进入大学，我能像马歇尔和莉莉一样幸运。
As a high schooler, I thought I was too sad and too weird to have that typical group of friends, let alone a romantic partner.
作为一名高中生，我觉得自己太悲伤、太奇怪了，无法拥有一群典型的朋友，更不用说一个浪漫的伴侣了。
As a result, I isolated myself and didn't partake in high school league things, like incestuous friend groups and best proms ever.
结果，我孤立了自己，不参加高中联盟的活动，比如乱伦朋友团体和有史以来最好的舞会。
Field hockey finals were in the fall, so I couldn't use that as an excuse like Robin.
曲棍球决赛在秋季举行，所以我不能像罗宾那样以此为借口。
It felt fitting that I watched the finale by myself, sitting on the edge of my parents bed with tears streaming down my face.
我坐在父母的床边，泪流满面，独自观看了结局，这感觉很合适。
Not because I was disappointed by the ending, but because I hadn't realized how much I needed a sitcom to punch me in the gut like that.
不是因为我对结局感到失望，而是因为我没有意识到我是多么需要一部情景喜剧来给我这样的打击。
Finally, I wasn't too sad and too weird for something mainstream.
最后，对于主流的东西来说，我并没有太悲伤和太奇怪。
With college on the horizon, I was able to imagine a happier tomorrow.
大学即将来临，我能够想象一个更幸福的明天。
Maybe I'd get into Wesleyan, following the footsteps of Ted, Marshall, Lily, Craig, Carter, and my big sister.
也许我会追随特德、马歇尔、莉莉、克雷格、卡特和我姐姐的脚步进入卫斯理学院。
On siblings weekend, I enjoyed my first sandwich outside my sister's freshman dorm, Butterfield, the butts, she called it, that's a fact, it is called that.
在兄弟姐妹的周末，我在姐姐的新生宿舍巴特菲尔德外面享用了我的第一个三明治，她称之为屁股，这是事实，就是这么叫的。
I could probably do that for the next four years, and my mental illness would eventually dissipate, right?
我可能可以在接下来的四年里做到这一点，我的精神疾病最终会消失，对吗？
Wrong.
错误的。
I was rejected by Wesleyan, first of all, Don't feel too bad for me, though.
首先，我被卫斯理学院拒绝了，不过，别为我感到太难过。
I'd end up among my people, AKA, other Wesleyan Reject.
我最终会和我的人民在一起，又名，其他卫斯理拒绝者。
At Skidmore College, where I'd play softball and double major in English and psych, salute major in English and psych.
在斯基德莫尔学院，我打垒球并主修英语和心理学双学位，向英语和心理学专业致敬。
And I'd visit my sister at Wesleyan occasionally.
我偶尔会去卫斯理安看望我的姐姐。
We'd even attend Craig and Carter's Hemium panel in the chapel and awkwardly wave to them outside the bathroom.
我们甚至会参加克雷格和卡特在教堂举行的 Hemium 小组，并在浴室外尴尬地向他们挥手。
I remember you.
我记得你。
My first few months away at college were a hard transition.
我上大学的头几个月是一个艰难的过渡。
I was making friends, but I created the security of family.
我结交了朋友，但我创造了家庭的安全感。
I felt like I was floundering at sea.
我感觉自己就像在海上挣扎一样。
Fish are weird, right?
鱼很奇怪吧？
But eventually I discovered that if I turned on the common room TV between classes, I might see the gang pop up on the screen making jokes.
但最终我发现，如果我在课间打开公共休息室的电视，我可能会看到屏幕上突然出现这群人在开玩笑。
I was already in on navigating problems I knew they'd get through.
我已经开始着手解决我知道它们会解决的问题。
It was like getting thrown a lifeboat each time the show was on.
每次演出时，就像被扔了一艘救生艇一样。
So thank you, Craig and Josh for the boats, boats, boats.
谢谢克雷格和乔什提供的船、船、船。
Two English degrees, several heartbreaks and a bad challenge accepted tattoo later.
两个英语学位、几次心碎和一次糟糕的挑战后来接受了纹身。
I am about to be 30.
我快30岁了。
In this stage of life, I relate to the gang on a whole new level, like how success often comes at the expense of our values or how love is the best thing we do, but it's not always enough.
在人生的这个阶段，我与这帮人的关系达到了一个全新的水平，比如成功往往是以牺牲我们的价值观为代价的，或者爱是我们所做的最好的事情，但这并不总是足够的。
Luckily, I'm less worried about finding the one these days.
幸运的是，这些天我不再担心找到那个人了。
My boyfriend and I just celebrated our three-year anniversary.
我和我男朋友刚刚庆祝了我们的三周年纪念日。
His name is Matt, the M to my L.
他的名字叫马特，M 是我的 L 的缩写。
I still fall asleep to him every night, just not alone.
我每天晚上仍然在他身边入睡，只是不再孤单。
So thank you for creating my comfort show, my guidebook, my family, and thank you for turning it into my new comfort podcast, it sometimes feels like I'm auditing the creative writing class of my dreams.
所以，谢谢你创作了我的安慰节目、我的指南、我的家人，也感谢你把它变成了我新的安慰播客，有时感觉就像我正在旁听我梦想的创意写作课。
It even makes me want to try screenwriting, which is scary, but as Ted would say, if you're not scared, you're not taking a chance, you're not taking a chance, then what the hell are you doing?
它甚至让我想尝试编剧，这很可怕，但正如特德所说，如果你不害怕，你就不会冒险，你不会冒险，那你到底在做什么？
Would you say I should make adjustments?
你说我应该做出调整吗？
Go get it energized Maggie.
去给玛吉注入活力吧。
If so, then challenge accepted love your favorite Wesleyan reject Lizette.
如果是这样，那么挑战接受的爱你最喜欢的卫斯理拒绝莉泽特。
That's a hell of a letter, Lizette.
这真是一封糟糕的信，莉莎特。
My God.
我的上帝。
Maybe Wesleyan is going to reconsider.
也许卫斯理安会重新考虑。
Maybe they'll give her on the second distinguished non-alumni alumni award like I got.
也许他们会像我一样授予她第二个杰出非校友校友奖。
You're going to talking with that thing.
你要和那个东西说话。
I have changed since I got that award.
自从获得这个奖项以来，我已经改变了。
You've been strutting around like the last year and a half.
过去一年半以来，你一直在大摇大摆地走来走去。
Josh, We did an event at Wesleyan, which will become a podcast episode, one of these days, right, Alex?
乔什，我们在卫斯理安举办了一场活动，这将成为播客节目，就在这些天，对吧，亚历克斯？
So keeping your head for that.
所以请保持头脑清醒。
And at the event, Wesleyan honored Josh by giving, because we part of these distinguished alum awards.
在活动中，卫斯理安通过捐赠向乔什致敬，因为我们是这些杰出校友奖的一部分。
And we're like, so moved.
我们很感动。
Oh my God, we got these things.
天哪，我们得到了这些东西。
And we're like, we're also giving one to Josh, the first non-alum distinguished alum award, and it was hilarious.
我们还给乔什颁发了第一个非校友杰出校友奖，这很搞笑。
Well, I think I said something along the lines.
嗯，我想我说了一些类似的话。
I've always felt that Wesleyan should give me something because I'm one of the more famous Fictional grads of Wesleyan you are what I mean, and I believe that was an Alec who said hold on At the event we're in front of a bun big crowd at Wesleyan and you said it and Alec is like funny You should say that and then it really is my jaw hit the floor It was great.
我一直觉得卫斯理学院应该给我一些东西，因为我是卫斯理学院最著名的虚构毕业生之一，你就是我的意思，我相信那是亚历克在活动中说坚持住，我们在卫斯理学院的一大群人面前，你说了这句话，亚历克很有趣你应该这么说，然后我的下巴真的撞到了地板，这太棒了。
It was a magical setup for that I was the recipient of the first ever Distinguished alumni non-alumni alumni word something like that.
这是一个神奇的设置，因为我是有史以来第一个杰出校友非校友校友之类的词的接受者。
It was well word We got to look it up.
说得好，我们得查一下。
We all got certificates, so you have it there somewhere.
我们都有证书，所以你把它放在某个地方。
We'll read it when we read it out loud.
当我们大声朗读时，我们就会读它。
We'll read it out loud when we do that episode.
当我们播放该集时，我们会大声朗读它。
But that was an absolute fantastic letter.
但这绝对是一封非常棒的信。
Absolutely fantastic, well-written, vulnerable.
绝对精彩，写得好，脆弱。
I'm really honored by that letter, Lizette.
收到这封信我真的很荣幸，莉泽特。
Thank you.
谢谢。
I know Carter would be too.
我知道卡特也会的。
I'm sorry, you didn't go to Wesleyan, go to Wesleyan, but the idea that the show meant this to you, and you found your path, and you found...
对不起，你没有去卫斯理安，去卫斯理安，但是这个节目对你来说意味着这个，你找到了你的路，你发现......
You had your first sandwich at Wesley, and for that, that's meaningful.
您在卫斯理吃到了第一个三明治，因此，这很有意义。
The first sandwich we had there is very meaningful, and you found the M to your L, and it's just, it's wonderful.
我们在那里吃的第一个三明治非常有意义，你找到了 M 到 L，这真是太棒了。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Please stay with us on the podcast because you're why we're doing this, so we really appreciate you.
请继续关注我们的播客，因为您就是我们这样做的原因，所以我们非常感谢您。
And if you want to send in a letter of, if you want to send in a letter of your own or a voice note that we might play at the beginning of the show, please go to how we made your mother dot com h w m y m dot com go to contact and follow the instructions pretty easy to send us a note.
如果您想发送一封信，如果您想发送一封您自己的信或我们可能在节目开始时播放的语音注释，请转到我们如何使您的母亲 dot com hw m y m dot com 联系我们并按照说明轻松向我们发送便条。
And then we also just point out that Lizette originally connected to us through the Facebook group.
然后我们还指出，Lizette 最初是通过 Facebook 群组与我们联系的。
So please go check us on Facebook.
所以请去 Facebook 上查看我们。
It's actually the major fans Facebook group are we rather than having our own Facebook page.
实际上，我们的 Facebook 粉丝群是我们的主要粉丝，而不是我们自己的 Facebook 页面。
Now we are we are we are collaborating.
现在我们正在合作。
We are over we are working with the Becky who because the great fan Facebook group and Lizette basically said, hey, I sent you a letter.
我们已经结束了，我们正在与贝基合作，因为贝基的伟大粉丝 Facebook 小组和莉泽特基本上说，嘿，我给你发了一封信。
And it was about this and that, I was like, oh, I'm sorry, I missed it.
这是关于这个和那个的，我当时想，哦，对不起，我错过了。
Send it again.
再发送一次。
And she did it and here it is.
她做到了，就在这里。
So join that Facebook group.
因此，请加入该 Facebook 群组。
We do actually read what y'all are saying.
我们确实阅读了你们所说的内容。
I'm there online and directing with all you.
我在网上和你们一起指挥。
And so check out the major fans group and there will be a link to that on our website too.
因此，请查看主要的粉丝群体，我们的网站上也会有指向该群体的链接。
Yeah.
是的。
Thank you.
谢谢。
It's the best part of doing this is here and from you guys.
这样做最好的部分就在这里，来自你们。
So please keep them coming.
所以请让他们继续来。
All right, thanks so much for joining us.
好的，非常感谢您加入我们。
We'll see you next time.
我们下次再见。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins are forgiven.
所有的罪孽都被宽恕了。
New York City.
纽约市。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并执行制作。
And it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
它由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 提供和分发。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
该剧还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制片人。
And the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作和编辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios, and our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer, Emily Blumberg, and associate producer, Catherine Grove.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Alex Reeves（blue studio 的一个点），还有我们的 Gen Z Masters、我们的数字内容制作人 Emily Blumberg 和副制作人 Catherine Grove。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
它确实有助于传播信息。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner, with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 创作的《纽约市》，其他音乐由克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 和安德鲁·马尤斯基 (Andrew Majuski) 创作。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢 Sam Theobold 和 Elliot Connors。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的 Muse Letters，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever books are sold, and read his other published writing at CraigThomasRider.com.
订购 Craig Thomas 的处女作《That's Not How It Happened》，无论书籍在哪里出售，并在 CraigThomasRider.com 上阅读他出版的其他作品。
And you could subscribe to my own Dead Father Society on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的亡父协会。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这展示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
will, in fact, dance.
事实上，会跳舞。